what's happening there reject nation we
got ourselves yet another clip of the
batman batman versus catwoman fight i
can't wait to see what this looks like
man if you can't leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated review embargo for
this movie lives on monday we're trying
to lock down an early screen looks like
we will be able to so keep a lookout if
we do have a review up on monday it'll
get delivered to you guys right away
we'll shoot it right at the theater
let's see what's in store people
[Music]
hmm
huh
this
you're pretty good at that
damn damn nice just goes right into
[Music]
make love to me
damn
every clip i'm just like don't stop
give me 40 minutes of the movie i
remember zoe kravitz i think a couple
months ago i want to say she was talking
about she talked about it several times
when learning the fighting styles for
this movie she studied like lions and
cats and how they fight and then working
with the choreographer they incorporate
like a lot of different types of martial
arts especially capoeira which you could
definitely see on display here i don't
know how this will play out in the in
the movie this feels like a real clip
kind of unusual part about the clothes
that they've been releasing is they feel
like real clips so what i mean by that
is usually when they release clips
online they feel like this feels chopped
down yeah it feels like it has the
pacing of a trailer whereas this felt
like it was just a scene that they
snipped out and didn't do too much too
yeah yeah i mean how quick do they go
into the fight will it be that quick in
the movie but in the way it played out i
appreciated kind of the immediacy of it
kind of like a cat-like reflex someone
shows up i gotta fight them i gotta take
them out right away and i like how it's
not like you just go to the closet or
something like that
it's instantly like martial arts kicks
that she's doing you know well yeah
there's still a stealth element of about
it there's still like even though it
seems like they're alone you probably
still don't want to cause too much of a
ruckus probably want to be as efficient
and effective as possible and i love how
you have such a tangible scene here i
mean there i think there was some music
but it's so intent on really letting you
live in the sounds and the tangibility
of the tools and everything and when he
sneaks up on her like it's a great
moment because we're all so used to
batman appearing out of nowhere and
doing the thing everyone hates and yet
even in that moment you know you're
expecting it almost and still i was like
oh damn there he is he's like i didn't
hear anything and even though movie
magic gets that done it still felt
really authentic in the scene and it
really put me in the shoes of yeah
focusing in with selena kyle on the safe
and then oh [ __ ] batman's here yeah it's
a celina kyle perspective i feel like
some of the music cues in this movie
will let you in on whose perspective
you're in yeah
yeah that's a good point because yeah
the fact of how batman seeks up on her
and like at least in this clip i don't
know if in the movie you'll see him like
watching her before he descends down but
i do like that it just cuts away to that
yeah it's like this the scene was a you
know a bit what we've always seen in
like a gazillion heist movies yeah you
know of how you break into some balls in
the
locker sound and stuff like that but i
do like the music by michael giaccino
there is sort of this like comic book
1930s flair yeah you are quality a
little bit of swing but with the fight
itself too what i thought was really
cool is how the story unfolds in that
little snippet of a fight batman is so
in control of it that he's not even on
attacking at all he's just letting her
do whatever she's got to do before he
take his move and take her down so you
get the password i guess my question is
that that looks like i would need to
revisit the trailer again it looks like
when we first ever saw anything at the
batman when the riddler is taping up
that one guy that no more lies on the
tape it looks like that's where the
crime scene is at and that's where
selena's broken into and that's where
she's stealing something so it would
make sense that batman would kind of be
guarding the situation because it's
directly involved with the investigation
directly involved with the riddler case
or something like that does selena
intentionally perk
her yeah she spend a lot of time there's
actually like little sponges stuffed in
there she has to readjust that
throughout the night because they come
out of place you know she needs
something a little more permanent
because this is her origin story and i
don't know if she goes by catwoman yet
i'd imagine at some point she would
she's called the bella clava right now
that's called the ski mask
what's funny about that is it looks like
it could just happen naturally but she
puts it on it just sort of forms that
way it perks up but it also seems like
maybe you should put a lot of time and
attention this is your calling card
right here you can imagine there's a
little bit there's a certain element of
pageantry to the folks of gotham
especially the ones who go out and do
crimes yeah yeah but to that point i
mean i i do really appreciate how like
subtly comic book this looks because i
mean that ski mask you know ears are
very much out of the comics but even
just looking at like the setting these
big tall windows even that establishing
shot with the police tape like i love
that this looks
really you know it's like you think back
at the history of batman movies and you
have the nolan ones that you know aside
from maybe batman begins get very much
like it's it's a movie it's gritty it's
realistic and then you have the opposite
end of the spectrum with like tim burton
and joel schumacher even where it's like
really really comic cartoon i feel like
this has a really nice split of the
difference where it's like yeah you have
these cavernous very eccentric very
interesting looking places but that
aren't too garish so that they really
feel immersive
and yeah befitting of a noir a comic
book but you know also without
distracting from anything that's going
on you know on this in the scene true
that man there's gonna be some great
[ __ ] can't wait to watch it sure enough
well leave your thoughts down below hey
let's do a p
all right john how's sarah campbell or
catwoman sarah campbell is our catwoman
because she steals things she's a
kleptomaniac sarah campbell i mean i
know
that you have an insatiable appetite for
the finer pleasures in this life but i
don't think this is a good path for you
i mean think about it you're out all
hours of the day and night running
around on rooftops who knows what you're
doing getting caught out in the rain
doing battles with other people out
there in the pitch black of the night
sarah why don't you go and get yourself
a respectable job you know stop going
down this path of misanthropy and crime
because hey we love you we want to
support you and if it's i mean
if that's the only way you can support
the patreon we understand but really i
mean i think there would be just a
better life path for you if you maybe
you know opened up a cat shelter instead
i think that could be good to surround
yourself with like a hundred cats you
don't even have to adopt them to people
you could just say that you're intending
to and there you go
cat lady for life
much less risk
that's how you're our cat woman sarah
campbell
[Music]
you